いやこれいつ見ても倒せだなポニーちゃん外れ社長です
お待たせしましたポテトチップスっ500袋プレゼントキャンペーンの発泡当選者発表
です
んあこの発表で発送するまでが僕は大変ですこれだけじゃないんですよと言ってねまだ
阿蘇箱これ全部クロス
その中もうね混ぜね正直あのストレスなんすよ
ずーっとどこ行ってもないかポテト10分ある今それ臭がして場所もないし撮影もでき
ないし想像つきませんよね
つかないと思いますありえないですから割と止まっていますポテトチップスだけど
ちょっと文に皆さんにこうプレゼントしてあげたいと思っているところで最初の方に
応募した方すみませんと素量はえっと皆さんが負担です話だったんですけども
レッドソールの方アナとちゃんとちょっといっか計算してみたんですけども1人当たり
約7000それ以上の額
の送料がかかることが分かりましたあの当選して流せとられてポテトチップスが100
袋所属のは当選とは言いません外れです出てこないですねもうあの僕のせいでもあるの
でと送料の方が僕が全部負担させていただきますぜひでと皆さんはもう送料も何もない
ということで普通に無料で50束プレゼントされるということ
でございます送料はなしでございます全部僕したんだね皆さんは何も次することはあり
ませんってこんなを解くだけだ言ってるマイナーにも早くみんな当選者発表するって
思ってるでしょ
さとみます殺到いきましょうピョンあのちょっと待ってうううううっえっとちょっと
個人情報門線ないんですけどうわぁ白菅山応募
それが全部で61500名の方が大もしていただきましたありがとうございました
食べてはじめとかちょっと
を伺いました将来面白い自分も同じミスを犯したことがありましてと約六豆の皆様
コメントありがとうございます
最初の3名は僕が何だの上の部分がいいでしょうね
あと2名はコメントがいいでしょうの2面ですじゃあ行きましょう何度も1人目
はいこの人を応
非鉄業
8私は去年からずっと肇社長のてっから youtube 見てました
その頃の初めて長が大好きで毎日1を見てましたチャンネル登録者数百万人本当にお
めでとうございます
すごい
すごいコメントがとても長いでこのようなコメントをさせてまいりました a
さやかさんこちらチェックせ空袋100袋おめでとうございます10
me
おめでとうございますどっち後あのうちの2つから連絡が行くと思います著者お待ち
ください
前髪きて変になってる月火が悪いんですよねでは2人目いきましょう
はいこの人ん
4月16日が20歳の誕生日でしたその時友達から混走にポテトスタースプレーを
もらいました
ティムールして嬉しかったんですけど肇社長からもらえばもっと嬉しいですマジで
はい暗殺さん暗殺ちゃんおめでとうございます
プロで観測それどころじゃないも100袋プレゼンですよね暗殺さんおめでとうござい
ます巻いては3人目ですそれがだんだんください分
はいこの1型ミッキーさんいつも見てます個別ほしいですくださいばのはらみっきー
さんおめでとうございます
ここからはコメント審査てございますスパッといいなって思って
チーズを包んだしてますね
無理でして音止めましょうってくれと言いますこの人に決定
じゃんホイロンさんでそめでとうございまーちゃんホイロさん
はいおめでとうございます嬉しいですねやめましょうっていう意気込みが面白いんちょ
イラスト
しているございました
コンソメ好き始めシャツをスキ
プレイ人と企画好きファーザー+タイム
奥山舞妓さんヌーしていきたいと思っにこちらですねこちらごめんのペット誓うちょっ
ちから連絡 vector
思うでねしばらくお待ち下さいません脱ぎデート今回当選しなかったかターン
ごめんなさいその100万人の時プレゼント企画できなかったから今回良かったなと
思っています155万256万人ぐらい登録者がいるので200万人入ったら是非
さらにで会プレゼント来なきゃできたらいいなと思ってまーすっだ次の機会に応募して
下さいじゃあやってりゃああああ
入った
ああああああ
pa